today only animes own revealed the cult
hit Bukka morning Atari and its sequel
is a monogatari directed by the highly
acclaimed a kyokushin bow and animated
by studio shaft a series described by
his own fans as a masterfully done work
of art in a completely new genre of his
own complete with amazing character
developments engaging dialogue
thought-provoking fees deep symbolism
[Music]
meanwhile at Studio shaft
when looking into the wide world of
anime I tried to keep an open mind for
anything new and original that could
potentially catch my eye but if there's
one thing that is guaranteed to ring
alarm bells a possible overrated nest
it's one masses of hipster plebs tried
to flog me a series by describing it as
a stunning original work of art because
aside from my natural fears the word art
being used as an excuse explaining and
being so convoluted it requires a PhD in
bullshitting to understand I feared that
the show could be so potentially your
underground it would be apparently too
cool for my mind to comprehend without
first donning some hipster glasses
wearing a French barre and speaking like
some pompous [__] so we have Bucky
monogatari and Easley monogatari two
series are so hip and alternative that
had literally farts out pretentiousness
the mornig artery series consists of a
collection of short stories revolving
around themes of the supernatural seen
through the eyes of a main character
Kuya Mia Draghi a vampire goes about
helping an array of different girls
solve problems brought about by these
different supernatural aberrations in
between taking a quick peek at her
breasts this could range from anything
from stopping a girl from turning into a
natok whose wet dream getting the [__]
kicked out of him by some chick with a
gorilla hand to helping an innocent
female with her crabs problem literally
that is at least when he's not busy
molesting elementary school kids making
out with his younger sister or raping
unsuspecting girls with his toothbrush
it's ray big time but we'll get back to
that later
now the premise of the show may sound a
bit weird because it's kind of difficult
to summarize what the show is really
about since it's so different well the
story is about a collection of
characters dealing with different
supernatural phenomenon behind a
backdrop of artistic scenery and set
pieces 90% of the show consists of
characters talking and talking and
talking and talking
sometimes it's about some supernatural
aberration and sometimes it's about
absolutely bugger-all
but in the any oils balls down to a
conversation where the wired counter
must absolutely not drop below a rate of
20 words per second otherwise a bomb
when the bus will explode or at least
that's the impression I got from the
email bloody talking that everyone does
yes as well as this may sound us
basically everything that happens
because it's essentially a show that
prides itself entirely around people
bullshitting so if you're looking for a
fast-paced series with lots of action in
it then you may as well shut this review
off now because while there are a few
fight scenes here and there that is
definitely not the focus of the
monogatari series at all this has made
evident as whenever there is a fight
it's more of a one-sided massacre
against the main character who would
much rather resolve all of these
violence situations by apparently
talking is opponents into submission
which always [__] works except for
this one rare time when he bravely Fleck
his muscles stood up proudly for himself
and fearlessly beat the [__] out of a
ten year old girl yeah that's right give
this guy a [__] medal but while my
description of the series makes it sound
like the concept for the world's dullest
anime the main strength of the show is
actually in its dialogue since it's a
series that relies heavily on
mind-bogglingly complex and engaging
character interactions both black him on
a guitar and these are known a guitar er
some of them works well written witty
funny and engaging dialogue I've ever
seen it's full of word plays pop culture
references and sarcasm while the quirky
our style and visuals combined to make
it some sort of symphony of dialogue and
color it's a very interesting experience
to say the least not something that
everyone would be able to appreciate but
I definitely give it a compliment that I
can describe the whole thing as people
talking [__] to each other if it being
the most engaging and interesting [__]
that has ever been talked so with the
show that basically revolves around
character interactions and dialogue you
didn't want the characters to be
interesting enough that carried the
concept and it definitely achieves that
the basic cast consists of rubber moraga
a long-sought a bunch of different girls
who are basically a collection of fetish
for different factions of the otaku
community to fawn over which i can go on
to describe one by one but I won't since
all you really need to know about to
send yoga Haruhi Targhee the sharp
tongue biting the sarcastic heroine that
had my ears glued to the audio every
time she was on screen her interactions
with araragi make up some of the most
complex and downright funny interactions
I've ever seen giving off just the right
mixture of sweetness wit and crazy
psycho [__] making her easily one of my
favorite female characters to come out
of anime as Fedora Raji himself well
he's subtly an odd protagonist switching
from a calm laid-back kid to overexcited
hyperactive sod - creepy child molester
like the wars most schizophrenic
pedophile but he's entertaining to watch
nonetheless even if he is a bit of an
unfaithful prick to his girlfriend
though then again what male lead in a
harem series isn't a little bit of a
prick can't overall the characters are
as complex as they are engrossing and
provide for a great balance despite a
fact that is basically just a harem as
for the other big selling point of this
show if he can't already tell from the
clips I'm showing you is the astara
animation the scenery resembled a
colorful take a modern-day avant-garde
Japan through the eyes of a minimalistic
crayon with everything looking
absolutely gorgeous production values
for both series seems to be
astronomically high especially in these
a mana gutter you are shaft apparently
had
much money left over from the certain
magical school go show that I'm sure no
one's heard about that they could afford
some set pieces so pretty and colorful
data might as well have just animated
the big pile of money they burn in
production to go along with the excess
of dialogue and solving the problem of
exactly [__] all happening in a scene
the series tries to keep your eyes
constantly occupied by rapidly changing
camera angles during dialogue like it
was edited by an ADHD stricken goldfish
speaking of camera angles this hard not
to mention the gratuitous amounts of
dodgy shots we got a female body
posturing conversation in an attempt to
subtly sneak him some fanservice in
hopes we wouldn't notice it in between
the bizarre scenery this might not for a
peculiar experience where I seen what
the screen was so me insecure and scared
of you getting bored from the excess of
talky that already constantly flashy
tits an ostrich or your attention back
like a subliminal ad campaign for hentai
though I'm probably over exaggerating
the imagery here I mean what the hell
would I know about suggested symbolism
it's art damnit art yes considering the
cult following has got in the Ganymede
community both series deftly stand off
being so different even in the creative
ways of portraying fanservice I
definitely have to give it credit for
being original and pushing boundaries
since some parts definitely left me a
lasting impression most notably was a
scene which would forever be cemented in
a collection of obscure anime scenes
entitled what the [__] did I just watch
a scene which involved a guy a girl and
a toothbrush which I was originally
gonna play out of context with some
unfitting music but you know honestly
what [__] context with his ever make
sense in
[Music]
well it looks like they just had some
oral sex in order to see I was talking
about how to feel about the monogatari
series as there were times when I was
just totally engrossed in their dialogue
and there were other times when I was
just listening to heads bobbing bored
out of my [__] mind to me my favorite
parts were when the characters were just
talking nonsense to each other and I
could just go up and admire the width
and cleverness of this nonsense
but when [__] hits the fan and something
corneum plot comes along why for the
[__] to sleep for this reason I actually
enjoyed these Lamonica three more while
araragi spend half his time wandering
aimlessly foraging for [__] I like
in Bucky more eager to reword more time
was spent with some sort Annesley
explaining some sort of supernatural
spirit or curse that I didn't give two
shits about meaning I'm most like an
only stomach watching two or three
episodes in one sitting because no
matter how well written or witty the
dialogue was my limited attention span
could only stand so much this compiled
with the collection of females acting as
a talky bait along with the excess
amount of dodgy camera angles and
imaginative fanservice
made me realize that this show could in
fact just be a fanservice harem show and
clever disguise not that there's
anything inherently wrong with that
except you might find yourself feeling a
bit weird where scenes of casual incest
or Lalique or nudity are treated as
normality or totally glossed over and I
only read there to provide material for
the entirety of 4chan to collectively
come over that and maybe Japan doesn't
yet realize that this is not normal
overall the monogatari series isn't for
everyone and it's definitely an acquired
taste
if hours of dialogue with some
perplexing character interaction
splicing between some artistic visuals
with gratuitous camera angles of female
body parts don't sound like your cup of
tea then stay the hell away from any
chance of getting conversed to death but
for anyone who's looking for something a
bit different and arty that doesn't
require a philosophy major to understand
then it's definitely worth a shot now if
he excuse me there's some toothbrush
porn and he's watching it's art dammit
ah
[Music]